[Music]
is
[Music]
welcome to the latest installment of ash
wednesday now by popular request my half
asian lawyer bill richman is here in
studio uh yeah he still works with us
but he's been working behind the scenes
on legal matters uh i want to let you
know this was
pre-taped
on friday uh on the legal matters that
of course are taking place with elon
musk and twitter and johnny depp and
amber heard we thought it'd be great to
have a world-class lawyer in but
if some of this doesn't fully make sense
because well this has changed i want you
to actually watch this through the lens
of we spoke about this on friday and not
only is he a brilliant lawyer
but apparently in oracle
because some predictions are made
that
in context now are uh
frighteningly
spot-on i'm on the road while you're
watching this taping uh some super
videos that are gonna be coming up here
in the future that i think you'll be
excited about but for right now enjoy
the uh
the crystal ball that is half asian bill
richmond this ash wednesday
[Music]
it's been a while since we've done one
of these it's been a while since we've
done
an ash wednesday and uh here
i guess by popular demand although he
never really went he never really went
anywhere but we get so many complaints
we hear you we read you in the comments
he's still working with us but he's
doing all the lawyering uh but we
thought now with elon musk and
johnny depp a lot of legal issues in the
news be perfect time to bring back on
the half asian lawyer bill richmond how
are you sir i'm wonderful glad to be
here can you tell people that we just
did you tell them you're i mean you're
still here
i mean i can say i get a lot of messages
i see people and they're always like
what happened and i'm like yo i'm
working yeah right like the half agent
might be the first part of the name but
the lawyer is the first thing and then
you trademarked it right right and then
i was like all right now i'm doing dmca
claims against other fake half asians
keanu reeves get out of here tiger bro
stick with golf i don't think he's half
asian he's like irish and mexican or
something
girlfriends
they'd say parts how much time do you
have
so hr tim's always been like hey get out
here you know token one was like get out
here and i was like i got the laws but
hey we're gonna talk about some fun
topics today no yeah i'm really glad to
to have you here and it's one of those
things where um
you were like i don't know you were
pinch-hitting right because we were like
there was a point where we were kind of
rotating third chair before dave was
here we just were trying out and then it
was just we were you know short-staffed
and so like hey bill can you come in and
then you just you happened to be good at
it and so then i kept asking you where
you were like i'm gonna have to go back
to being a lawyer like okay but i mean
it helps when i change myself into the
third chair and you were like well
okay i guess we'll make this work it was
half asian snake moan yes and i was glad
to mm-hmm
so
oh by the way we're smoking today uh
masters blend uh three from oliva and uh
shout out you can actually get the uh
crowder seven plus one sampler at cigars
daily a friend of mine uh over there tim
uh tim a good guy has a great channel
and uh not a sponsor of the show just
the guy's been a solid dude so you can
do the uh crowder seven plus one sampler
has by my uh my favorite cigars there
and he's giving you a good deal that's
cigarsdaily.com so let's start first
before we get to the salacious stuff
with johnny depp elon musk
uh with twitter yeah i'm not a lawyer
and you do obviously you do a lot of
business uh law if i'm correct that is
correct so
seems to me like he really has the
board's uh pecker in a twist
uh yes uh it's it's been super fun to
follow watch you've got law twitter's
been blowing up about it and which is
ironic given that twitter's at the heart
of all this but in the long run it's uh
you know it's a lot of bluff calling you
know elon essentially saying i'm going
to openly try and change the face of
something that i don't like and now the
board is stuck between you know
exercising their poison pill trying to
do shareholder rights plans you know the
fiduciary duties can you explain to
people because the term poison pill is
thrown around quite a bit i mean here's
the layman's interpretation of it elon
musk basically said
uh hey i will buy out twitter i will
gladly buy an at something like a 20
higher than the uh the market evaluation
at that point if i'm not mistaken
significantly higher so i'll buy it
outright to 100
and then he said and if the board
doesn't accept my offer i may have to
reconsider
my stake in twitter which we know would
probably cause their stock to take a
nosedive right
so that's those are kind of the options
but then people have talked about how
the board instituted a poison pill and
even jack dorsey said this is their
dysfunction
what does that even mean most people
don't know what the poison so i mean a
poison pill is a general topic it's a
general concept of something that's
going to make the acquirer not excited
about acquiring the company or make it
harder to do so generally what that
means is you've got shareholder rights
plans you've got preferred pricing the
ability for other shareholders to buy at
a discounted price or a cap on what
powers you can exercise once you reach a
certain threshold so normally in these
kind of takeovers you'll get someone who
acquires a position 9.2 in this case but
then they'll go to 10 they'll go to 15
they'll go even higher than that and
your corporate raiders which is the 80s
and 90s terms when this first came
around
the boards had to figure out a way to
stop them so they would say well we'll
put together this thing that's going to
maybe hurt the company
but but maybe not we're just trying to
slow the process to make sure that
everyone ostensibly gets a voice right
so that's what the poison pill is it
makes it it makes it harder for elon to
do what he needs to do he's gonna have
to get more people on his side than just
him by himself which is how you could do
it without the people so it's like a
legal turd in the punch bowl
it's a turn to the punch bowl 100
and it's basically one that says you
can't even lift the turd out of the
punch bowl by yourself right you've got
to get other people to come and help you
to do it but that's where you see the
interesting part about how elon's been
very public the polls on twitter about
how about the features about what he
should do how he should do it you know
being you know he had to disclose of
course through the sec
all of the offers that he made but
notice the language he's using right
yeah he's not just playing towards the
board he's playing towards all of the
shareholders of twitter across the globe
to say who do you want run in these
things a couple of folks you know a
couple of men and women who have very
small interests
but here's the questions why would they
do because you're saying they need to
take everyone's sort of voice into
account uh seems like the primary voice
should be the shareholders and correct i
would imagine the shareholders would be
very happy to make that much money and
to get something that high above market
valuation
so when we say everyone gets a voice are
we talking about people on the board or
the shareholders so
they're
claiming that this is on behalf of the
shareholders but you're right so they're
lying
i would suspect that they don't actually
know that this is in the best interest
of the shareholders so the way they
couch it is
well we're trying to understand whether
this is in the best interest of the
shareholders right because you had one
of the saudi princes came out and said
well i think the intrinsic value of
twitter is much higher than the offer
and that's ultimately what it comes down
he doesn't know how to handle money he's
a prince he was born with money and
carpets he's got oil everywhere yeah
there's a you know oil derrick in his
bedroom i'm only half joking i hate when
these you have these people who are
basically born into royalty or
ill-gotten gain or gain that they just
didn't earn by themselves and they try
and tell everyone else oh i know
business like no you don't you were born
into it what do you know about what i
think you i don't know if he was one who
came out and said was actually worth
significantly more at one point yeah
three years ago right twitter's been
consistently doing this so when i see
this is another sort of how i see it and
i think how a lot of how the public sees
it it sounds to me from what you're
saying they're almost using legal
maneuvers that kind of reflects the
exact suspicions that we've had it's the
elites and power the board those people
versus the people who actually want to
see uh real change at twitter namely in
the direction of free speech and that's
even a lot of the shareholders it's in
the interest of everyone except for the
corporate board who want to maintain
control so what you haven't seen the
board say yet but what you've seen other
people say particularly on the left is
oh he wants more free speech that's
dangerous yes right and and that is
while the board isn't saying it that's
what everyone sees they're trying to put
forward they're trying to say well if
elon is going to do what he actually
says and make this platform more open we
really want to pump the brakes on that
and they're using the legal maneuver to
say well we're investigating it we're
evaluating it we're trying to understand
now the one part that they do have leg
on is there's not a competing offer
right so right now it's not like someone
else has come in and said other than
just the market value of the shares
right right no one's come in and said
this is what we're willing to offer or
is this ownership group good anyone
who's done any investing knows that you
know you can buy a great horse but you
put a bad jockey on it no good right
right they have to be at least five
four foot five or below yes exactly
that's all i know about jockeys tall you
lose you're not oompa loompa you're just
a small skinny like danny devito would
be gargantuan for a jockey right right
no good no good that horse is going
nowhere right but here you are going to
a person who has successfully built
multiple companies and multiple
industries who has successfully
leveraged the very company itself
through his platform become one of the
biggest voices and of the top 10 the
most active yeah of all of the top 10
with follower accounts on uh on twitter
and they're saying well we're just not
sure whether or not he really knows what
he's doing and it's in the best interest
of the company so what we're going to
see now or shortly is you're going to
start seeing shareholders take action
they're going to start sending demand
letters those will become public they're
going to start sending disclosure
requirements if you have a big enough
stakeholder depending on the rights that
twitter has under their stock plan you
know hey what is the evaluation that
you're doing why are you doing it this
way and ultimately people will start
suing you will find shareholders who
will say nope we're going to take the
board uh and try and hold them
accountable and and really bring a lot
of this to light it's going to be
interesting if well first off if you
have to bet do you think elon musk pulls
it off do you think he buys twitter
i think he gets it i think he gets it i
think one way or the other he's going to
get it but i don't think he's going to
get it by himself they've already done
the poison pill but i what i think the
twitter is bored is miscalculating and i
think what i would call you know left
twitter is miscalculating when they get
out there and they scream i don't want
free speech elon musk's free speech is
right it's dangerous it's it's fascist
it's it's totalitarian
that the average american and the
average shareholder is looking at that
going
um so if if the twitter board has on its
side a saudi prince
pretty much everyone else should agree
that this is the right thing yeah tell
you what saudi prince when your women
can drive by themselves we'll start
talking about free speech okay what do
you give the over under if if uh jack
dorsey get uh sorry jack dorsey if elon
musk gets twitter how quickly before
donald trump is reinstated uh i think
it's pretty quick yeah i think it's
pretty quick i mean the the the and then
he says truth social i never loved you
anyway well i mean we we've we've seen
this across the variety
of of tech platforms companies even you
know kind of behind the scenes amazon
you know and what they did with parlor
et cetera is the question of who's
allowed to use these services or not and
what is unquestionably
downright devious
applications of their roles right right
you've got uh you know you've got a
interim interim afghani government
not enough air quotes for me to put
around all of that who are allowed to be
on twitter you have literal terrorists
all over twitter yes and we can't have a
president of the united states we
couldn't have him while he was the
sitting president of the united states
right exactly because they want they
imply that and of course the most free
fair election ever just have to be clear
because this part is on youtube of
course no there's never been any problem
with any type of mail in voting
whatsoever at any point okay all the
caveats just for him saying
hey you know what let's look into some
of these uh what he believed to be
discrepancies that's it that's right
that's considered a threat to our
institutions and he's gone the ayatollah
khamenei is still there like you said
interim governments of afghanistan still
there it's um you know dinesh d'souza
talked about this with me and i think
we've gone over this
you don't have a country of laws just
because you have laws you really only
have law and order if the law is applied
equally and i think
especially with this explosion of big
tech it's not really something that we
were prepared for it's always funny to
me when you hear
leftists say like oh well the second
memo was back when there were only
muskets which we know was untrue there
were cannons there were purple gun uh
puckle guns jiren done air rifles they
were high-capacity guns
but this is one of those things where um
it was very hard to imagine a handful of
companies that were more powerful than
any national or world government and
don't have the kind of regulatory
oversight that just ford motors does
right
and uh that's that's a tough pill to
swallow i think for people who used to
be libertarians you're like well it's a
business they can do whatever they want
yeah but not when it affects elections
and it's a de facto public square right
or or or just the the the common concern
of you say you have a policy you're not
you're not applying it equally you know
this is deceptive right you know you're
you are telling folks that this is an
open platform when it's really not and
and all of the real credible i mean some
people are you know they'll say well i
don't understand and i get these all the
time people reach out and they'll say
well i've been you know the platforms
are messing with me and i'm like well
but what you did is very obviously a a
problem and these were the rules highly
illegal like i don't know how to tell
you this but like you're going to waste
your money giving it to me and on this
particular instance and so so i tell
them and they go well i think it's
unfair and i go well that's that's not
the way it works they can set out what
the rules are they just have to apply it
fairly and what elon's most credible
complaint has been is how are you
deciding who's banned how are you
deciding the tweets to get on look at
libs with tit talk what's going on right
there look at the
countless accounts that have been um you
know manipulated have been shadow banned
have been dealt with in in unfair ways
and when elon comes in and says let's
just stop doing that
and the board goes crazy they start
saying well i don't like that it makes
more clear the agenda look if even if he
doesn't get it right maybe i'm wrong
maybe he doesn't pull it off
the light that has been shed here
his offer his tactics have put a
spotlight on what the board is and that
of anything is they can't hide from
pushing this agenda yeah it's often why
people uh when people ask me like why
don't you think about running for office
because look at what someone like in
elon musk i'm not comparing myself all
to elon musk but look what he was able
to do in the private sector versus the
politicians who we know many of whom
we've spoken with have been just having
hearing after hearing after hearing and
accomplishing nothing right he's already
accomplished more just in making the
offer like you said that's changed the
dynamics and if he actually if he
actually
gets twitter okay
and he starts applying rules fairly
it will force and even youtube i know
people don't think of youtube as a
social platform it's more of a media
consumption platform
but even youtube and certainly facebook
instagram it'll force them to have to
follow suit
because too many people will feel
they'll feel restrained right
so it's again it's the free market as
more effective than someone with an r
next to their name
all right so i think and we can talk
more about uh when we go to mug club uh
uh you know youtube and how you how we
met how a half asian lawyer billersman
and i met you can hear the origin story
and um kind of the changes just that
we've seen in you i mean dramatic
changes uh that have happened on the
platform i was just talking about this
last week but we can move okay to johnny
depp this is something everyone is
talking about
uh lawn crime i think youtube channel is
is one thing that's actually doing
really well as far as streaming right
now on youtube because they've changed
that too uh
this is a scenario that has people
really riled up again what i see is
almost everybody with whom i speak goes
i just can't believe amber hurt is such
a monster because they've listened to
the audio with her admitting to hitting
johnny depp and mocking him and pooping
in his bed
um but there was still an article from
variety talking about how this shows the
privilege of rich white men and again
there's that disconnect right um
how do you
how do you see this case playing out and
and what do you make of some of the leak
because this is a defamation case yes
right so to be clear for people who
don't know i don't want to waste i don't
want to sincere by the hour i don't want
you to have to explain the beginning
part so uh she left johnny depp file for
divorce claimed that he had assaulted
her okay then instead settled right they
settled out of court she got seven
million dollars and then wrote a veiled
article on washington post yeah about
how she's a survivor of abuse
and uh of course the direct inference
was that it was johnny depp right and
then that caused him to lose uh at least
50 million dollars i mean his pirates of
the caribbean job so he is suing her for
defamation because he's saying he never
physically assaulted her and as a matter
of fact she did to him and committed
mental abuse
what am i missing is there anything else
that people need to know in there before
we kind of get into the sort of details
of what a horrible person is well i mean
those those are
long and in depth and we're going to get
into those what's important is folks
have already kind of forgotten the
original where this originally came from
in the legal realm which was his lawsuit
uh against the sun so under you know
under british law
they called him a wife beater right the
wife beater and you know their
ultimately under british law they had to
prove it and in what johnny depp's
lawyers described of the trial result
there that it was a perverse and
bewildering
ignorance of the evidence right i mean
they literally the judge in their the
way that they described it was just
ignored testimony evidence written
evidence oral testimony recordings etc
about what amber heard was doing in her
litany of wrongful acts i mean the
demonstrating that she was neither
afraid of being abused had not been
abused
was more clearly the person who was
engaging in the abuse here's the thing
when you say that i didn't i have been
looking high and low i haven't seen any
evidence that she's presented of abuse
beyond her claiming so and at one point
claiming that this mark came from him i
mean she's she's got a lot of
circumstantial inferential right well
this is you know the marks the
conversations taking certain contacts
you know what what she's done is just go
out there in this instance and say look
at all of the crazy things that he's
done which anyone who's lived a life has
done crazy things where in a photo taken
out of context a snippet you know you
always say take a snippet look at the
first 30 seconds before look at the 30
seconds afterwards and then you'll more
likely know what is the truth yeah like
last week i said i want more women who
are raped to come forward
and uh you know bring their accuser to
justice or to carry a firearm so they're
not a victim of rape and some people
just took i want more women to be raped
just that kind of thing
right cutting the sentence off you know
i mean you see you see this example all
the time right the the lion the lion
who's holding the cub by the neck and
you're like yeah no no no that's that's
the cub of that mother lion right and
she's dragging him to come with the
other cubs because there's an alligator
over here right and so the context is
what matters and so in that sun lawsuit
he lost and they were able to prove in
the opinion of that judge in the
judgment that abuse did occur though
though that judge did say that there
were a number of instances that she
alleged abuse occurred and they were
like nope didn't happen so already in
that original lawsuit her claims were
found to not be entirely credible now he
went and tried to appeal that to the
british court to the next level shut it
down and they said no it's not enough
and and i gotta tell you some of that is
you know i haven't read every all the
pleadings and all the evidence but it
seemed strange that they weren't able to
even under that other legal system to be
able to challenge it but now let's fast
forward to this lawsuit right you know
we're we're you know we're not all the
way through we've got you know different
evidence is still going to come out in
testimony but you're right the the
there's a paucity of evidence on her
side there's a lot of evidence on his
side to say that what she was talking
about i mean first of all the fact that
she's even trying to say well it could
have been about anyone
i'm sorry what yeah yeah the article
right not not specific during that time
when she was married to johnny depp and
in subsequent interviews she's given
commentary that again makes the
inference oh you had a guy on the side
and he was abusing is that the is that
the uh the guessing could have been elon
musk that's also one of them right that
johnny depp said not not one month into
her marriage she was uh she was a stupid
elon musk that wasn't exact words but
something like that i mean i think right
next to the [ __ ] on his side of the bed
that he found was a cyber truck key so
you know it was very although he was
very happy to be the first person to get
one yeah but it was a welcome gift i
haven't seen any evidence from her side
and and i want to get to okay it's a
defamation case here in the united
states
um correct me if i'm wrong and then i
want to get into sort of um
the importance you know we talked about
this last week marriage and marriage
laws in the country and how it now is
discouraging people from getting married
because it's just a risk that men don't
want to take and it's one of the only
contracts that i can think of in the
united states
where
if one person makes significantly more
money
one side is financially incentivized to
break it in certain no-fault divorce
states sure in other words there are
women let's say a woman is not wealthy a
woman has never worked a day in her life
her best bet to get rich in certain
states is just to marry rich guy
there is that does exist i don't know
it's cynical but the truth is but i
would say that that's you know this
might cut against it a little bit it's
kind of a tale as old as time right it's
not quite as old as the world's oldest
profession right but you know the the
mrs hasn't been a joke for you know 100
years because it's not all that
different from the world's oldest
profession well at times and that that
would be part of the question right like
what was the purpose here look at anna
nicole smith and her situation right
yeah um ended up you know with big goose
egg no she just she just liked 90 year
old wrinkly turtle look-alikes
i mean don't tell my wife but oh yeah no
i'm kidding i mean so so when it comes
to that situation there's a couple
different aspects right there's
the marital aspect people have also
asked a lot of questions i've got
messages from folks who are asking about
the criminal side right like where are
the where are the police
to do the investigations
on both sides right who's done what
what's happening there and that appears
to be a very little part of what's going
on well i think it's a little part
because she admitted to her physician
she admitted that she punched him right
and he admitted to his physician when he
was cut and beat you know he cut his
finger that she threw a bottle at him
right right and people said why did you
lie well he lied to people who weren't
the doctor because he was embarrassed
and he told the doctor what she told her
physician so in other words everything
that will be on the record would there
be consequences it's pretty consistent
but before we get to the marriage thing
let's start with the defamation issue
because i think a lot of people uh may
not fully understand this and they they
just go i like johnny depp i like amber
hurt defamation is one of those things
and it's separate from media right a
third party let's say a newspaper and it
it kind of needs to be where they need
to be they need to reserve the right to
be incorrect not be malicious right you
know and knowingly lie but people get
things wrong all the time sure
it's a little different when you're a
public figure and this is the person in
relationship with you so from what i
understand with defamation it's a pretty
high bar to clear and if you're not a
public figure right you need to prove
that you lied
that you lied negligently when it's a
public figure that you lied with malice
of forethought so even more that you
lied to a third party which in this case
obviously had taken place and then that
there are significant reputational
damages that you need to prove is there
something else that i'm missing or is
that kind of the bar i mean that's
that's in broad strokes yes i mean
there's you know for example there's a
limited purpose public figure which is
between a private citizen and a true
public figure then there's there's i
mean there's endless case law about how
someone crosses in that threshold of
being a general public figure and
whether or not they have to get to this
malice standard you know that you knew
what you were saying was wrong right
yeah and and this has always been the
tension of the first amendment and we we
did that um
uh you know changed my mind down in
front of google in austin yes um where
or mr jones they couldn't not answer us
fast enough right right they uh the
security guards loved us but uh yeah i
don't think the employees were super
thrilled that's the untold story it's
like
no one knows that the security guards
usually could have been dicks and like
get that on here but they were like i
like what you're doing you know what's
so funny it is like shades of fight club
right where they're like we're
everywhere right yeah yeah yeah we cook
your food we guard your homes right and
it's like yeah no there are real
americans everywhere and so in your
ivory towers you know just realize
you're talking [ __ ] about americans yeah
for people who haven't seen it by the
way you can go and uh we'll have a link
in the uh description uh half fashion
bill did come with us to awesome we need
to change my mind out in front of uh the
google had the google headquarters in
austin this was the one where you almost
got shaked oh yeah they tried to throw a
milkshake there was something else in
that milkshake though but yeah there was
a key for southern lookalike from lost
boys right yes yeah
that was a good one but but we talk
about this tension right which is people
to be able to say things to be able to
say them and in certain instances you
know whether through comedy or news or
otherwise you know for the public good
there's a lot of kind of exceptions to
you can make statements that may you may
not know
are 100 true but you have a good faith
reason to believe they're true or you're
doing it for the public good and there
are exceptions there here this is not
the case right this is someone who's in
the relationship with the guy right not
only she in the relationship not only
did they have a resolution not only did
she do the op-ed not only did she try
and skirt around what her agreement had
been but then it's very clearly intended
to be wrong like there's no way to be
like well you know i heard from amber
that's what happened and i interpreted
her words and so i said something about
it this is her saying first person i was
there
these horrible horrible things happen to
me consistently and
you know don't listen to my uh you know
my phone calls don't look at anything
i've written don't look at any of the
facts by admission of pooping out of bed
right and none of those things are
relevant i i just was horribly horribly
abused by johnny depp right and so
we have to allow and what what i think
really makes people frustrated on the
left is that they they have this ideal
that we can just solve all these
problems that there can be no
offensiveness no uncomfortableness no
you know that we can shut down speech
that we don't like and here just start
by hashtag believe all women it's like
well that's the end of that right it's
like we're just gonna we're just gonna
believe no matter what whatever is gonna
happen we're not gonna take any thought
to evaluate it and here the argument is
the same right it's the other side of
the coin of saying we're just gonna go
say what it is it needs to be believed
and you know we're just gonna let it
happen but what are we doing about false
accusations yeah false accusations in a
marriage false accusations in the
workplace false accusations in public
right i mean you've got terence howard
right you
did a thing gone on video it is what it
is right you've got other folks who have
been wrongly accused and everyone just
remembers the accusation yeah they don't
remember the back end what's happening
happen yeah i mean we've got a ton of
situations like that and people still
run with it people still run with things
that after the investigation which was
conducted was proven to be false for
example that party didn't happen on that
night it couldn't have and it couldn't
have happened in that house because it
didn't exist and those people couldn't
have possibly been there right um and
people still run with that right and
they just remember that accusation and
those in the media unfortunately because
there's such a fear of there's such a
lack of fear of any retribution or any
even accountability right they just go
with it and i that's also what i see
with an amber herd in this this is
someone if you listen to the calls the
taunting the you're not a man you're a
[ __ ] you know these kind of things see
who they believe this is not a woman who
is afraid of being
abused and this is a woman who also
admits on the call to abusing him and it
doesn't seem like it's a woman who fears
any accountability in a legal system and
i will say get a lot of messages from
young men as someone who has been you
know an open advocate for the
institution of marriage
but i am conflicted because there's the
biblical view of marriage in a holy
institution
and then the government really has
screwed it up in a lot of ways with
divorce laws where it is kind of that no
fault is not no fault
um
so what is that what are the
consequences for example all i keep
hearing about defamation is it's such an
incredible hurdle to clear it is
yep i mean shouldn't it be we're talking
about civil but if she actually lied
about something right it's provable
shouldn't there be criminal penalties
for perjury well so it's there are it's
the question of what are they all
reinforced right right it's that
prosecutorial discretion i mean people
were you know our juicy small a
situation right i mean people were
frankly shocked that it got even as far
as a trial much less a conviction you
know and because it just rarely happens
now it doesn't not ever happen it's
pretty rare though it is very rare and
and it comes in very extreme public
situations or it comes in situations
where it's a slam dunk and they're
willing to just do it but a lot of the
times you know in our in our the way our
criminal system is set up overworked
prosecutors who have long long long long
dockets longer than you can imagine you
go into any da's office around the
country they've got long lists of
products and when they have to choose
between murderers embezzlers you know
those types of things and then
going and prosecuting someone for making
a false claim it tends to fall to the
bottom regardless of the harm of the
true victim which is the person who's
falsely accused right so then it it's
incumbent upon people to go out and
prove
you know through the civil system what's
going on but then that puts the full
burden on that individual how many
people would be able to mount a lawsuit
like johnny depp without his resources
you know which which her accusations are
actively hurting right um and it makes
it makes the average person very
concerned i get the same messages right
i mean about folks who say well what
what can i do in this situation how
could i have an open conversation um you
know whether in the employment context
whether in the school context hey i want
to have an open discussion in a
classroom well now you've got to start
biting your tongue
more you've got to start unless you're
teaching second graders about uh about
correct assistance correct if you if you
are doing uh some of those public
library conversations yes uh you know
where we have drag queen story right
right yes exactly um also school
assembly we showed that last week a drag
queen school assembly like if this were
just a woman
effectively stripping at an assembly it
would be pornography but because it's a
drag queen it's like oh yeah i wasn't
stripping okay
but but but that's but that's the the
question is are we going to force these
laws i mean this is
the end all be all is if you do not take
action
against false accusations you create an
environment where people don't feel like
they have any protection
i'll tell you what it feels like for a
lot of people watching
a lot of people watching think this
woman was in your cigar went out if you
need to relate it that's fine i can take
the torch for a little i can take the
mantle for a little bit do you have your
lighter i do okay um
you know i showed you how to do the
purge fireball trick right no that's
where you toast it you light it
and then you blow out and it'll create a
fireball and that'll purge that sort of
ashy taste that happens when a cigar
goes out no i like i like i like
astronomers okay all right well that's
fine little zoolander you like your
cigars like you like your women old and
ashy
oh my gosh my wife is gonna fight you
yeah i know your
your wife is
far from as a matter of fact i don't
think i've ever seen a woman with more
porcelain-like skin than your wife that
was the first thing i noticed it's that
whole i got to tell you it's that whole
mix
it's a whole mixed race thing
it's like you know you mix the colors
mutts are taking over the world look
when the chinese armies you know breach
the california border i will designate
you as one of the uh thank you i'm gonna
have to say you're an indentured servant
yes yeah yeah well they'll kill me last
yeah yeah i'll be like no no i need that
guy she digs the ditches right you need
one more puff that's gonna it's gonna
drive me nuts if you don't do it so i
will tell you what it looks like and
what i think and what i think most
americans think because they look at
this johnny depp scenario they go
all right seems pretty damn clear that
she at least abused him
doesn't seem clear that he physically
assaulted her everyone it's pretty
undeniable that she physically assaulted
him because she admitted it to him on a
phone call she admitted it two third
parties there's evidence of it
she doesn't even really deny it
now it's the question of did he
physically assault her i haven't seen
any evidence so most people watch this
going okay
at best this was a tumultuous
relationship
between two parties
at most likely this was an abusive
relationship from a woman to a man which
we talked about last week is actually
far more common than male to female the
domestic abuse incidents same thing with
single mothers versus single fathers
it's like 200 and something thousand 230
something thousand uh you know mothers
abuse their children physically versus
only 130 something thousand fathers per
year a lot of people don't know this
because the story doesn't get told and
that ultimately harms children but most
people watching this saying this is a
woman who was abusive emotionally
physically to johnny depp and did
undoubtedly cause it caused him to lose
his job
um through what she said
but i don't think anything's gonna
happen anyway because the hurdle is too
it's too high to clear that's how most
people
watch this they go this is a guy and i
don't even like johnny depp i'm not a
fan at all i always thought he was kind
of an affected prick but my heart goes
out to him i feel like most people are
watching this and they this is when
people lose faith in their institutions
where they go this seems really clear
but we have no hope there no i'm with
you i don't like pirates i don't like
caribbean i didn't like the movies
either i don't like black pearls mr
sparrow no not my favorite hate birds
you know but
ultimately you gotta envision yourself
being one of the the parties here and
feeling like
is is justice gonna happen do i have the
most americans don't think it will that
it won't be motivated by politics or
because of a personal animus is the
system gonna work and look the system is
gonna play itself out and we're gonna
find out and people are always gonna say
you know i hear this from clients i hear
this from folks who are just commenting
on the system they go well you know the
trial court got it wrong and i was like
guys we've had appellate courts to
review trial courts since the beginning
of courts so
we've already known that there are going
to be times when your trial courts are
going to get things wrong and that's why
you have the appeal system right but
that being said it doesn't remove the
frustration of knowing that to get there
is going to be a problem i tell people
all the time they come in and they say
oh i want justice and i say well let me
just let me just stop you right there if
it was justice you wouldn't even have to
be talking to a lawyer someone would
just
you know
just decide and the decision would be
done correctly and you wouldn't have to
go spend money or relive the pain or
have to deal with the accusations right
um but but that's where our system is
and you're right people are losing the
faith to believe that we're going to
look and apply the law fairly whether
it's policies at a big tech company
whether it's the laws on defamation
whether it's
what i would say is
it really a
hypocritical
application of the idea of equality so
many folks on the left will say well you
have to believe all women i'm sorry i
thought all people were equal shouldn't
we believe have you met many women and
women or men or z's like
generally speaking i don't believe all
of anything i believe
less than the plurality right because
most people lie and and when you have
folks who come in and go well
you know it's a guy versus a woman so
i'm just going to believe the woman or
folks go well you know look that guy
made some really bad movies he must be a
liar that's a little more facetious but
folks would say look
he's he said he he drinks
he sometimes gets a little wild
sometimes he does things that are
deplorable or immoral that doesn't mean
he did the things she's accusing him of
and you have to let
you have to let the system play out and
then on take this one yeah this thing
just went out and then i needed to purge
it and then you got to get people to
back up and enforce it because someone
like amber heard
who again like you've been saying like
we've been seeing lack of evidence on
her side lots of evidence on his side
how do you do that i can't even get that
do that right
it tastes good now
damn it all right no i think you're i
think you're and i think
the problem is
and i think that a lot of people are
frustrated with
is the believe all women is a hashtag
right
people say that's on okay most people
say that's unreasonable believe
women don't
hear all women for sure hear all women
and then
innocent until proven guilty that's most
people right
again with the subtext that many men are
scumbags we kind of all know that
i think the problem is
that's a hashtag but it's also
sort of a foundational stone of our of
our current legal system as it relates
to a lot of marital law oh there's no
question as it relates to custody as it
relates to no question yeah and and
that's
that's what is unfortunately eroding far
more than this idea of same-sex marriage
it's eroding marriage because states are
basically saying
well if you're a man and you're a
provider you you really have ultimately
it's what the woman says goes and that's
and you have to prove that it's not true
and like you said if someone's another
resources of johnny depp well they lose
their kids or they lose their shirt
right
well there's like a big distinction
right like you know your mom for example
stand-up woman honest hard
great you know has her opinions
hilarious accent everything about her is
great
my mom we my mom and i have had a lot of
disagreements i mean i've talked about
it before on other ash wednesdays about
you know we had times where we disagreed
where i felt like her upbringing made it
hard for her to raise kids in a
different country than the ones she grew
up with and other things like that and
and those prejudices and you know
insecurities came into her relationship
and then i had my own as we came into
our relationship but the idea of saying
well you know what i my mother was great
my sister was great my grandmother's
great so i'm gonna believe all women
because
you know there's an idea that
the majority of women are oppressed or
assaulted or harmed is is going against
the grain of what our legal system is
founded on is that we are going to take
these accusers right with these
accusations and judge them on their own
i mean even just so on in the divorce
side of that okay maternally that means
they're better off when the fact is like
statistically it is undeniable that
single mothers commit abuse against
children more than men we've that's
undeniable and by a large margin but the
legal system says well they should
automatically go to the mother because a
mother automatically loves them more
than a father right and there are so
many dads out there who and i get emails
to say i don't i don't care about
alimony i think what i don't want to
lose is you know my shirt on child
support because i know i'm not going to
it's not going to go to the kids right
i'd rather put it in a trust fund i'd
rather give it directly to the kids we
have a court system that says basically
you give this money to the mom and the
mom is going to look out for the best
interest of the kids and i think that's
where a lot of people see themselves
even though they didn't parent children
together johnny depp and amber heard
where so many voiceless men or women who
were the daughters of men treated that
way or sisters go
this is the problem with our court
system right and and it's and it's
been seen in
numerous cases where you know one
parent says you know let's say for
example oh i'm a i'm a doctor so i can
take care of my kids better this this
woman doesn't know anything you should
give them to me well are you a good
father that's the question flip it to
the other side well i'm the mother i i'm
definitely going to take care of them
okay but you
the children don't want to be with you
they've made allegations of abuse etc
well we just we're going to apply all
the good things that these other women
did to this situation and we're gonna
we're gonna institutionalize
that bias when we need to evaluate the
situation and the number of dads that go
into these situations in the divorces
into disputes or even after they're
divorced right yeah the alimony
situation the child support situation
this system is built in in almost every
single state and every court that you've
gotta the dad comes in one or five steps
behind yeah and and it's unfortunate or
the husband even if there aren't kids
and that's what we're seeing with johnny
depp i mean right
i guess how do you see this going and
then we'll go to we'll go to mugler how
do you see this going with johnny depp
and amber heard because the evidence
seems overwhelming with recorded phone
calls with the testimony of people who
would whose testimony would actually
matter i don't just mean james franco
right but i mean doctors physicians were
like actually this night this is what
she told me actually this night this is
what he told me and then the recordings
of her saying yes i hit you there's no
recording of him saying yes i hit you
there are medical records of him dealing
with the injuries from her throwing a
bottle at him
um
how do you see this playing out because
again it's not it's not a a case it's
not a criminal case regarding battery
it's a case regarding defamation
is it too high of a bar to clear and if
that is the case
is there any kind of hope for reform to
a legal system that you know puts people
uh on an equal
footing the first thing i'm going to say
is this this is not for you because you
get the terms right but for all you
people out there saying is he is he
going to go to is she going to go to
jail or is he going to go to jail at the
end of this civil lawsuit y'all that's
not what this is about this is monetary
damages get it right before you start
tweeting about it but
we still we still got more evidence to
go we've still got things to go in the
trial we've still got rulings for the
court even after the evidence is in to
determine whether certain things are
still in whether they can be considered
what weight they're going to give but
you know it's looking as though the
evidence that really needs to matter
gets in so many people will go to a
court and they'll say well
i heard everything i watched every
minute of the trial i heard every bit of
evidence that came in i heard everything
the jury heard
you know if there's a jury in the case
right and and i came to a conclusion but
what you forget is that the judge can
make decisions about what evidence come
in right in the criminal case motions to
suppress evidence that never comes in or
evidence that's never given by the
prosecution to help the person in the
defense right similarly in a civil case
evidentiary rulings that were made in
the beginning that will impact what
evidence is even shown in the first
place but here you're getting to see
so much more of the evidence that in my
mind it's painting more of the real
story than what happened in the sun case
before right but that comes down to that
is going to bear more in
johnny depp's favor to be able to clear
that high hurdle
it seems to me like maybe the likelihood
is they say okay sure this was you know
defamation but uh we're not going to
give you the money
they could they could they could go and
say this was a false statement it was
never true
but you know no everyone thought you
were a bad actor anyway so you weren't
going to get those movies that fantastic
piece spin off like
you know nobody wanted you were you were
a has been anyway so he's going to have
hurdles there too right i mean he's
going to have to jump over all those
hurdles because someone decided to make
false accusations uh against him and
he's going to fight every part of that
as the plaintiff he's going to fight
every part of that how
how can people hope to see change like
you just mentioned this is civil
uh how can people be hopeful that the
system is reformed so there are criminal
charges brought against people who make
false accusations that destroy people's
lives because destroying someone's
livelihood is a much bigger deal than
people give it credit like oh well you
know what you're still free to do it's
like yeah but the person can't make a
living
this is the least the least sexy thing
is the most effective thing
get active
if you're in a state that has elected
judges look at the judges look at what
their what their backgrounds are the
number of of judges who are being uh
elected in the positions at the trial
courts the appellate courts with not
only
no experience but actually maybe even
worse is folks who have detrimental
experience who don't know what they're
doing they're the ones that are
hamstringing the parties from really
being able to get you know any semblance
of justice or even being heard to tell
the real story and let it let the chips
fall where they may with the true story
right so you've got to get active in
those elections but even talking about
your political positions your appointed
positions the people who are appointing
the folks who decide what the rules are
your legislature who decides what are
the rules of evidence oh you you can go
ahead and bring these kinds of claims
there's no way to just deal with it
early on like an anti-slap lawsuit yeah
right at the beginning those it's very
unsexy i know people are already no i
know they're shooting out with legal
issues it's very local it's i mean you
can have one county over and it is it's
an entirely different legal critical
i mean that's why this uh some people
were saying it was a big deal that this
is in
uh virginia as opposed to california
because that's where you know i think it
was the washington post is where the
article was posted and the laws are
different where you may have a better
chance that's how big of a difference it
can make and that is also how much of a
difference you can make being involved
locally more so than i know it's tough
with politician when you're thinking
about presidents and senators like well
how much can they really do they have
one vote a judge can make a huge
difference and your local legislature
can make a huge difference as it relates
to um what is allowed in in your courts
and and maybe an unpopular opinion but
i'm going to say it anyways there are
you've got to look past the r or the d
or the l or the i next to the name on
the ballot if you're in a in a state
that votes or if you're in a state that
does like retention voting or that kind
of thing because there are judges who
are dedicated to following the laws in
both parties you've got to look past it
just like you're going to look past
the fact that a mom happens to be a mom
and that they're going to be good for
the kids you got to look to the
substance of these candidates these
judges these elected officials and
really dig in and look
tweeting's one thing you got to get the
words out people got to do that i'm
encouraging you to still tweet that's
important but you've got to take other
action if you're going to see change
otherwise we're going to go the way of
people who don't trust their government
and believe that anything the government
is doing is probably wrong and that's
not what america is we got to fight for
the corps of america which is a legal
system that actually works right
i don't think it's entirely misguided i
think that there's a lot wrong with
america's institutions right now but
you've got to do more than just [ __ ]
about it okay speaking of which you guys
let me know uh who else you would like
to see in the next ash wednesday and we
kind of do these intermittently because
a lot of people it's not like tim poole
by the way tim hello love you buddy
where everyone has to come out in studio
but when we do the ash wednesdays we do
since it's a sit down long set down we
want them to come in studio let us let
me know comment below who you'd like to
see
should we should we stop swatting tim is
that is that no it's well yeah it's not
i mean it's still funny
it's still funny it is funny but still
funny
next time we'll just send pizzas uh
swat pizzas yeah yeah um we'll send jets
fighter jets uh
so uh also cigars daily you guys can go
and get the crowder seven plus one
sampler again they're not an official
sponsor of the show but tim over there
is a great guy and he has a great
youtube channel if you wanna learn about
cigars we are going to actually discuss
some of the origin stories and what's
been going on with big tech on mug club
youtube pissed off